el presidente que no coló divisiones que
ha dicho que su país renació el día que
las tropas rusas atacaron ucrania
ocurrió hace seis meses y mientras tanto
moscú no desvela si va a haber un cambio
de estrategia el ministro de defensa
ruso serguéi shoigú ha dicho que si hay
una una ralentización en el avance de
los rusos en ucrania se debe
precisamente a su interés en no causar
bajas entre la población local pero en
realidad llevan más de seis mil muertos
en ucrania desde que empezó este
conflicto desde el lado ruso se ha
rechazado la idea de obtener una zona
desmilitarizada en la en torno a la
central nuclear de la policía mientras
que los ucranianos insisten en que
durante los próximos días puede existir
cualquier tipo de provocación por parte
de rusia incluido ataques en kiev contra
edificios del gobierno